では よろしくお願いします
今日のテーマはこういうテーマでございます
あの今日は儀式について喋りたいと思います
で まあ儀式ということはね
まあ儀式 祭りっていうのはなぜかわからないんだけど
人間がとても大好きなんですね
で まあ理由として言えるのは
この恐怖感 不安感和らげるんです
まあいろいろまあ不安があると
恐怖感があると まあ昔から何か儀式をやって
はい 大丈夫やと言ってくれるんです
で そういうわけで まあどこでもいっぱい儀式はあります
で それから道に対してね
まあある将来ですね 道って言えばね
まあ将来のことっていうのは誰もあまり知らない
だから不安が出てくる
そういうわけで またいろいろ儀式をやって
あの将来はまあどうなるかとかね
いろいろお祭りとか神社の祭りとかはね
来年の豊作はどうなるの？好作になりますか？凶作になりますかとかね
そういうお祭りの結果でまあ決めてしまうんですね
そういうことで この道に対する不安も儀式で和らげてくれますね
まあ一番わかりやすい例は
まあ楽しいんですね 儀式は
祭りは まあそれはもう何とも言えませんだけど
まあ楽しいんだったらどうしようもないんですね
もうやめたくはないんです
祭り 儀式で楽しむのはもしかすると子供だけかもしれませんだけどね
大人にしてみれば まあそれ死ぬほど心配する大変大事なことかもしれませんですけど
それから希望 願望 期待というものに応じるんです
ということは 実際結果が出るわけっていうことではなくて
まあ何か希望が願望があると
それだったらこれこれこれの儀式
祭りやってくださいと言われるんですね
だから自分の希望 願望に応じてくれるんだから
祭りっていうのは まあ儀式っていうのはもうなかなかなくならないんです
例えば合格祈願という希望があるならば
合格するというね まあそれに適した儀式を用意しておくんです
それで我々は合格祈願する何かないのかと聞いたら
やりますよと で 子供が欲しい女性がいて
子宝に助けられる 授ける何かありません
あります ありますよと
すぐもう提供するんですね
そういうわけで この我々の願望
期待に応じてくれます
で それからまた真面目な原因なんですけど
人間関係を作るために役に立つんです
実際具体的に見ると この楽しみがあることと人間関係ですね
祭り 儀式っていうのは一人でできるものじゃないんですね
いろいろ人と一緒にやらなくちゃいけない
そういうわけで まあ何かの目的で人間関係を作ることはできるんです
はい 次に この儀式 祭りっていうのは
本当は宗教の特権になっているんです
何かの信仰に伴わない儀式
祭りはありません で どんな儀式
どんな祭りを見ても 何か宗教に何かの信仰に関係あるんです
ですから 宗教と儀式っていうのは一つになっています
宗教の関わりをカットして祭りだけを行うようにする努力も見えますけど
まあそれは現代的にね
なんかかっこつけて 我々は文化的に祭りやるんですけど
まあ宗教は関係ないんだぞとかね
いてやってることは信仰してやっている人々よりダサいというか
気持ち悪いというかね
あの まあ例えば日本の宗教は興味はないと言って
誕生日会とかクリスマスやってるでしょうね
あれって何や？と聞きたいんですけど
で なんで誕生日でろうそく立てて何かもうふっと消すんですかね
なんで食い物の上にろうそく立てるんですかね
どこまで頭がよろしいでしょうかね
それでかっこつけるのは宗教と我々は関係ない
我々現代人でインテリで知識人でということでね
まあ鏡で顔を見て言うならばね
もう 本当にこの宗教と関係ないとやっているところは一番最悪なんです
もうじりじり信仰なんです
大体宗教的にやる場合は
まあ自分たちもよく参加してみますから
まあやっちゃいましょう
もう昔やってるんだから
どうなるんでしょうかとかも
お互い聞きながらね まあすぐ早く終わりましょうという
あんまり真剣じゃないんです
で 信仰でやってる場合は
信仰はいらんとやってる人々はえらい真剣でね
だから言いたいのは そう簡単に儀式祭りから宗教のことを切ることはできません
一緒なんです まあ例えば
年の暮れ クリスマス 誕生日というものは
まあまあ宗教的な儀式なんですけどね
まあ日本ではハロウィンもやってますけどね
しかし 宗教的な意義を切ることは不可能です
そんないくら頑張っても宗教的な意義を切ることはできません
まあ例えば日本ではね
まあ日本の伝統的な宗教はゴミ箱に捨てたんですけど
その代わりに一斉にキリスト教の儀式を受け入れたんだから
何の差もないんです  よりあの年代的に短くて
もうダラダラしている
しっかりした歴史もない
まあいい加減なもう儀式でしょうね
キリスト教っていうのはそんな歴史もないし
ただ人の考え方をパクってパクって作った宗教でしょうに
いまだに教え このことがはっきりしてないんですよ
いまだに疑問だらけで
何だろう 何だろうというね
だからまあ仏教 日本にしてみれば
神道とかね まあすごい伝統のある歴史のあるものがありました
そんなのは嫌と捨てたところで
じゃあ宗教捨てられますかというと
何のことなく もう片っ端からキリスト
クリスマスをやると でお寺でもやります
それで考えてほしいのは
宗教が先ですか？もう祭り
儀式が先ですか？と あるいは宗教が先に現れて
それから宗教があらゆる儀式を作ったのか
あるいは儀式があって
それが宗教に乗っ取られたのかどうか
どちらかなんですね どちらと思いますかね
これはあまりよくわからないんですよ
歴史的に調べてもよくわからないんですね
ほぼ一緒っていうことなんですね
宗教と言いながら儀式をやったりしたもしたし
儀式に宗教が乗ったりすることもあるし
例えば自分の国の場合は
このインドヒンドゥー教の儀式である
このお正月 これ4月13日ですけどね
13か14 まあそこら辺で星の位置によって日にち変わりますけど
それは明らかにヒンドゥー教の祭りで
ヒンドゥー教の中でもこの年号を課せられるのは
このシャカというお釈迦様の釈迦じゃないんですけど
別な釈迦という王の時からなんですか
それはそんなに古くないんです
あの 1700ぐらいかな
まあそんな古くないんです
で そこで年号を数えたりして
まあうろ覚え裏内の世界ですけど
まあ文化はインド文化だからね
まあそれで向こうはお正月やっていて
じゃあ我々はどうしようかというと
やっぱり正月やりましょうということに
儀式やることになるんです
でもこれヒンドゥー教の儀式だから
どうやればいいかわからなくなっちゃうんですね
そうなってくると それで仏教がそれに乗るんです
乗って仏教的にお祭りやるんです
まあそういう風に この後から儀式に
後から宗教 宗教がそれ乗っ取る場合もあるし
まあ逆もあります まあ例えばお釈迦様の誕生っていうのは
テーラワーダ仏教というか
自分の国だけなのかもしれませんだけど
ものすごい盛大に確実にやる
で まあその場合はまあ宗教が先にあって
それから儀式が始まったということになるんですね
しかし 宗教が組織化する過程で
人の祭り 儀式 文化 習慣などを乗っ取ることだけは確かです
そこで宗教っていうのはどんどん組織化していくんですね
あの初期時代で キリスト教っていうのはものすごい小さくて
ほとんど隠れて 誰も知らない状態で信仰していたんで
エチオピアとか まだまだその原型のキリスト教がありますけど
で しかし どんどん政治的に権力を握って
政治家をつかまって どんどん広げていくんですね
広げていくと 世の中にある儀式を全部自分で乗っ取るんです
それでカトリック教っていうのはもう面白く
そういう宗教なんで キリスト教じゃないんです
あれは あれはローマ帝国のあらゆる習慣
儀式であり で 周りいろいろところにあったいろんな習慣
儀式でありを乗っ取って乗っ取って作った集合体なんですね
だからはっきり言えば
カトリック教の人々はイエス様を信仰していないんです
マリア様とかね なんだらかんだらの仙人とかね
は信仰しているんです
聖書は見せるだけで あんまり読もうとはしない
このプロテスタントとかね
この人々は聖書ばっかりに締めて読んでますけど
カトリック教は全然もう別にお祈り文句は全部別に書くんです
だからどこまでというか
キリスト教かとわからないんですけど
まあ十字架ぐらいですね
だからこの そういう風に
この宗教が組織化している過程で
他人の儀式を自分がもう乗っ取る
日本のお盆は何なのかというと
この日本人 中国人というのはこの死者儀礼やっていたんです
それが仏教に取られちゃったんです
ですから このお盆は今どちらかというと
今ではわからないんですけど
まあ仏教の祭りなんです
しかし もともとはそれは仏教が乗っ取ったものなんです
別に仏典ではどこにも死者儀礼をやるということはまるっきり一言もないんです
ないんだけど まあそれから日本でお地蔵さんというものをよく信じて信仰しますね
あんなのは仏典にはないんですよ
それはもう今お地蔵菩薩ですからね
仏教は乗っ取っちゃったんです
で 昔人々はこのアニミズムというかね
何でも神やというふうなことで信仰していたんですよ
だから ちょっと変わった形だったら
そこら辺で神様がいるんだからとかね
山にある ちょっと心配だったら
そちらに何か石一個でも置いておいて
拝んで神様ありがとう
守ってくださいと入ったりする
で そういう風に至るところに
どんなもう畑であろうか
田んぼであろうか もう狩りに行こうか
もう漁師として海に出ようか
何やってもどんな怒らにしたっても
何かを信仰して拝んでやるという
原始的時代からやってきた習慣があったんですね
それが仏教に乗っ取って
もういろんなお地蔵さんを作っておいたんです
そうすると やがて人間は忘れちゃってお地蔵菩薩っていうのは
これは仏教のことだというふうにと思っているんです
だからどんな形のものでもお地蔵っていうふうに言えるんですよ
今も  そういうふうに宗教が組織化すると
人のお祀り儀式を乗っ取るということもあります
なんでそんなことをやるのかということをあまり知りたくはないでしょうね
やっぱり大したことないんですよ
自分の宗教はよく広く知られてほしいというぐらいのことです
だからカトリック教は野蛮人が野蛮人だと他の人々に悪口言いながら
これ 人間っていうのは鏡で自分の顔を見ないということはね
よく助かるんであって
だったら人に向かって野蛮人だと言わないんですけど
思いつもものすごい原始的なしきたり
習慣というのは腐るほどあるんですよ
例えば人類の初期時代で
まあ神っていうのは女性でしたからね
インドでもそうなんです
一番このモヘンジョダロという
何文明っていうんですか
巨大文明の時は神は女性でしたけど
昔の人々はもう本当にまともなことを考えるんですよ
だから物を生んでほしいんだから
豊かになってほしいんだから
破壊して欲しくないんだからね
だから産むという場合はやっぱり女性ではないかと
だからいまだに大地は女性なんです
まあ女性としても言うし
女神の神というふうなという言葉で
いまだにその単語だけは残ってます
で そこでカトリック教というのはものすごい女性を差別して追い出しますよ
しかし 人間が昔からね
まあ母を神にして信仰していたんだから
なんのことなくそれを取り入れたって
マリア様を信仰することになるんです
だから教会の数重ねてみると
マリア様にのために作っている教会の方がものすごい派手に多いんです
バチカンのセントピーターズというね
キャテドラルがあります
あれはピーターさんの
あれ なんだかなんだかというんですけどね
それはローマ法を認定するための言い訳なんですね
アメリカ キリスト教のことをあまり知らないことは言っちゃってもまずいしね
で それでなんで人の 信仰
人の儀式 しきたりに乗っ取るのかというと
やっぱりより広く自分の宗教を知られてほしいんですよ
だからアフリカでキリスト教っていうのはかなり違いますよ
日本のキリスト教もまた違いますね
ヨーロッパのキリスト教と随分違います
そうやって変えるんです
変えるところはほとんど儀式的なところですね
そういうことを考えちゃうと
祭りが先にあったんではないかと考えられますけど
まあそれはあんまりはっきりはわからない
宗教と祭りの関係でも
弱者が強者に食われる現象はあるんですね
私が言いたいのは まあ宗教と儀式
祭りのことを考えても
結局はあの弱者が強者を食ってしまうという現象なんです
だから おまじないやったり
人に祈祷してあげたりした人々が弱者でしたから
ヨーロッパでは魔女狩りやってみんな殺しちゃったんです
もしそのグループが文化的に立場が強く
土台が強かったならば
キリスト教は何のことなく一生懸命大量の自分のテキストを作ると思います
大したことないんです
そんなに真剣なことじゃないんです
しかし キリスト教論から見れば
隠れてあっちこっちで女の人たちが病気になった人に何とかおまじないしてあげたりとかね
することがあって 見る限り
こっちの人々から見れば
なんであんな連中何やってるのかとかね
自分たちが立場が強いし
政治的 経済的権力を握っているし
それで異端異端と言いながら魔女狩りということになっちゃうんですね
で イギリスで書く小説やらね
何でもほとんどたくさんありますけど
この魔法使いの話は多いんですね
アメリカではあんまりないんですけどね
で 理由は未だにやっているんだからなんです
だからどこかでこれはもっと根深いんだよと
この信仰はということをね
言いたいんですよ だからハリーポッターみたいな話は
いとも簡単により世に広げるんです
いくら反対しても意味がないんです
はい それでは儀式を 3種類に分けてみます
1 病気を治す 商売繁盛
幸福守りを祈願する 現世利益の目的
この現世利益のために現世利益はたくさんありますけど
いくつだけ書いてんであって
目的で儀式やる  2 死者の霊を慰める
葬式や供養などなど  3 自分自身の心を清める目的
いわゆる修行の目的で儀式をやるという 3種類があるんです
この 3つに入らない儀式があると思うならば
どうぞ教えてください
私の頭ではまあ 3つに全部入ると思います
それから一つ一つ説明していきます
これ知ってますか？これって現世利益のね
一つの儀式なんですね
あの これこぶっちゃえば全部穢れがなくなって
悪がなくなって清らかになって
希望が叶うという信仰ですね
だいたいこの第1現世利益の儀式っていうのは一番人気あるんです
これやらない人っていうのはないほどですよ
地球上で 地球上の人類はみんなこの第1の儀式は一応やってます
私にまあものすごい現実主義だからね
まあ文句は言えませんよ
例えば自分の子供が病気になって
これ石であろうとも 蛙であろうとも
お願い お祈りしたら治してくれるならば
治るならば なんでやめるんですかね
だからなんとも言えないんですよ
このチヌアってチヌアでしたっけ
これと面白いんですよ
これ例で これあのこぐるんですね
こぐる方があります まず中にこぐって
それから右側に行って
また戻って またこぐって
また左側に行って またこぐってとか
そういう 3回こぐるんです
それからこれもチヌアの同じ儀式なんですけど
これこぐれない人々は
自分の汚れやら罪やらいっぱいあって
なかなか清らかにならないだからね
それで名前を書いて お金いくらか納めてあげるんです
あげたらこの箱に入れて
これをくぐってあげるんです
それで自分が清らかになるという儀式なんです
これも日本中どこでもやってます
これは仏教的な儀式で
この経典のさっと火災を送ったら
もう全部煩悩もなくなって
もう悟りに達するんだぞと思っているんです
経典を読む必要はないんです
書くでしょう それもまあ一応現実薬の儀式なんですね
あの あまり他のものには写真は出せませんだけどね
で お札 お守り 占い 祈祷などたくさんあります
病気を治す祈り 儀式などもありますね
で 敵を倒して勝利を得るためのものもある
しかし 金に頼ると豊かになるように
儀式にお札に頼ることで幸福になる
商売繁盛するという 具体的にはちょっと言いたくはないんですよ
言えないんですよ 例えば
金に頼って金いっぱい持っている場合は確実に贅沢できますよ
私は金を信仰して 金を御守りにしているんだぞと言っても
あれは嘘じゃないんです
だって金でいろんなことできるんだから
私はこのお札に頼っているんだぞと言ったっても
お札は何かやってくれるかどうかね
お札はどんな働きで商売繁盛してくれるかどうかね
それがわからないんですよ
説明もないんですね だからどういうわけかわからないんですが
人間はいろんな品物に頼ったりはする
2番目に死者を慰める儀式
宗教に興味がなくても
無宗教であっても 葬式儀礼は行うでしょ
頭だけで偉そうなことを言うんだけど
実際はまあ儀式中毒ですよ
例えば 無神論者たちが自分の親戚とか誰か亡くなったら
電話一本で遺体がありますけど
それ燃やしてくれませんか？とかね
そういうことはしませんよ
そんなに無神論で論理的であれやこれやと言うならば
人が死んだらどこかもう葬儀屋さんに電話一本かけてね
そのまま持って行ってくださいと言って燃やしてくださいと言えばいいんだけどね
もうやっぱり結局はやるんです
自分の国でたくさん本を書いたお坊様がいて
もう亡くなられてますけど
我々もよく仏教 その先生の本ですごいたくさん書いています
勉強しましたし 私たちは知っている年になると
もう結構お年のお坊さんでしたけど
100 歳まではいかなかったんですけど
かなりお年で亡くなられたんです
しかし そのお坊さんはもう根っこから仏教で
そういうことにはもう全然
全然もう入らないんです
儀式儀礼には そこでスリランカでお坊さんが亡くなったら
派手に祭りはやるんです
そのお坊さんがもう全国で知られていて
そのお坊さんの本を読んで学んだ生徒たちといえば
もうほとんどスリランカ人なんですね
一般人も読むんです すごくわかりやすく書くんです
ですから まあ自分で学んで学んで
そういうわけでお坊さんに礼をしようと思っちゃうと
もう全国みんな来るんです
もし私も知ったならば行くんです
私は一応何回も行ったことはありますけど
私は先生の弟子から学んだことはありますからね
で そのお坊さんがもうほとんどもうお年になって
もう短い時間にまあ寝たままでいましたけど
その時はみんなにちゃんと書いておいたんです
私が亡くなったら それはもう早く
あの 何と言いますかね
あの 引っ付きは要りません
ただ木の枝でなんとかつなげて
その上に遺体を入れて
そこら辺にお寺のあちこちある薪を集めて
何か作って燃やしてください
それから終わりましたとみんなに全国に報告してください
亡くなられて葬式終わりましたと
言って約束されて その通りになったんです
だから葬式に誰も行ってないんです
毎日お布施持ってくるその日曜学校の子供たちと
このお母さんたちとお父さんたちが一緒に来て
この偉大なる方をただ燃やしただけ
それを厳密に仏教的な方でしたから
そうなったんであって
他のお寺ではまるっきり違います
ものすごい もうもうむちゃくちゃ
もうお祭りやるんです
宗教を嫌う人も何かの祭りをして冥福ぐらいは祈るんですね
儀式を行わない 行わないで仲間で飲んで食べて楽しいパーティーをやる人もいるんですけど
もう何人も法事も何もやらないで
ただ火葬場に持っていって
それから自分たちでご飯を食べてパーティーやると
それは自分たちすごいインテリだと思ってますけど
まあ結局はね 知識的な考えではなく
単なるわがまま ケチ以外何でもありません
それは どうったことないんです
あの 私は例に出たお坊さんみたいに
一般人にあっちこっちもう全然迷惑かける必要ないんだよと
お前たちがお菓子を一緒にずっとご飯持ってきてね
食べさせて 私はそれをご飯食べて
仏教の本を書いて書いて全国みんなに仏教を教えたし
だから死んじゃったらあんた方が燃やしてくださいと
いうのはすごい立派な考え方で
だって全国からいろんなぶったな人々が来ると
あの村人たちに何の立場もなくなるしね
だからお坊さんはそれはすごい親切に考えておいたことで
まあそうでないと まあやっぱりただわがままで
なんで葬式やらなくちゃいけないんでしょうかとかね
言うと 私に聞くのはあんまりも自分のことばっかし可愛がっていて
亡くなった人に対して微塵も感謝の気持ちがないんじゃないかな
だから私に個人的には葬式
儀式 儀礼やりなさいとかやめなさいとどちらでも言えません
我々仏教的にいるのは
やっぱり教えになった人々に対する感謝っていうのは忘れちゃうと
あなた方は人間なのかということなんです
だから この我々を教えるなんて
我々を育てた方々が亡くなっても
その恩恵を覚えておかなくちゃいけないし
それが儀式で表現するのかということは別な話なんです
盛大に儀式をやる場合は
結局自分のためにやっているんです
だから結局 葬式儀礼っていうのは
残された人々は自分を慰めるためにやっているんであって
死者を慰めませんよ そんなことで
もう死んでいるんだから
だからまあ だからあまり意味がないとも言えるし
だから言って亡くなった人はきれいさっぱり忘れなさいというと
これは人間らしからぬ行為でもありますね
だから何とも言えないんですよ
まあ一応葬式儀礼っていうのは
こういう風に結構派手にやるんです
ちょっと時間ないんだから
私の写真入れるの忘れちゃ
私にはそんな立派な葬式はないと思いますけどね
これは一応本物じゃないんです
まあデータ取れないんで
本物の それも一つの儀式というかね
迷信ですね 日本では  3番目
修行 という儀式 滝行 断食
裸行とか ものすごいたくさんあります
宗教が儀式であるということを言えるぐらいなんですね
もうすごいかっこよく儀式をやっているのはヒンドゥ教なんですね
で 昨日夜 ＮＨＫのちょっとスイッチ入れちゃって
ヨガの番組がありまして
なんか可愛い女の人が女優さんでしょうと思いますけど
インドに行ってヨガをやるって
ものすごい長い時間かけて
これ書くの時間なくなっちゃったんです
随分遅くまでやっているんだから
だからもう一度ヨガをね
あの まあインドも今は豊かになっていて
すごい金持ちがもう誰でもヨガやることになりましたということで宣伝するんです
それで裏を読めますからね
我々もやりましょう 我々も金持ちじゃないか
だからもう一度ヨガブームにしましょうということですけど
まあやっぱりもう話を聞いているとね
もう 信頼できない連中だなと
例えばリシケシは一番派手に紹介したんですけど
リシケシってところ インド人がすごく行くのはなぜかというと
ビートルズが行ったんだからなんですよ
情けないんじゃないんですかね
ただの若者がね まあ麻薬中毒の
で まあ歌はすごいよろしいかもしれませんだけど
金もあるかもしれませんだけど
それでそっち側に行った
それだけでインド人が随分血が湧いてきて
ヨガやってる これは 2000年
3000年前からやって
何言ってるんですかね
だからこの儀式に執着しちゃう
自分たちでも何言ってるのかやっぱりわからないというかね
それにこのリシケシで外国人に指導するのは
これまた面白いことに日本人なんです
女性 女性にね 指導するのは
まああれって儀式だからね
よくやってます 現代宗教では結局は修行は何かの儀式を行うことになっているんですよ
だから宗教はどんな宗教であろうともね
日本の宗教であっても
ヨーロッパの宗教であっても
イスラム教であっても
宗教といえば儀式であるということになっているんです
だから儀式をやって神を体験するとかね
まあまあ悟りに達するとかね
まあいろいろ神秘体験やるとかね
そういうふうに頑張っているんです
キリスト教の洗礼 懺悔なども儀式だ
礼ですね これは まあ儀式に反対とか
迷信に反対というキリスト教は
自分たちがやっていることはすべて儀式なんですけど
まあそれすべて儀式なんですね
では 何かの形をとることで
あの これ何だったか 数を持つことで
特定の服装で心が成長するのかとはよくわからないという仏教的な批判ですけど
あんたお数を持っているんだから
あんたの心きれいでしょうかとかね
とにかく形で表しをしているんですよ
で しっかりと十字架をね
もう体に付けたまんまであるとかね
バチカンに行ったらものすごいそういうお守り売ってるんですよ
だからまあ時々ね 見学に観光に行く人々も大量にそれは買ってきて
友達にも配ってあげる
これバチカンから買ってきたものですと
やってるんです だから日本の神社でお寺でやっていることとは全然変わりはないんです
問題は 十字架を首にかけているんだから
あるいはポケットにあるんだからって
あなたの心はそれで綺麗になるのかどうかね
ちょっとある日まずいことになりまして
ある日本のとてもとても有名な方がね
あの私にあの あんた方はお数を持っていますか？とか私に聞いたんです
その方のお寺に関係ある方で
私はね あんなのは持ちませんよと
もし我々の坊主がね わざとお数を持っているならばね
明らかにインチキ坊主やと
もう話になりませんよと
言うとすごく気付いちゃって
実は私はいつでも持ってますよと
僕 これがないと落ち着けませんよと
あ それ申し訳ございませんでしたと言ったんですけどね
それ先にそれ言ってから聞いたらいいですよ
どれもお偉い方だからね
まあ失礼なこと言ったらいけませんし
だからそういう品物にそんな力あるのかどうかね
まあ一概にまるっきりないということでもないんですけどね
まあ雰囲気によってね
人の心はそれなりには変わりますよ
まあそれぐらいでしょうと思いますけどね
はい これで終わり 儀式について
今日のテーマに入ります